and we are the gun trace task force
no matter what you're doing out there in
those streets jackpot [ __ ]
your word prevails
the story of we own the city is about
one of the most corrupt squads in
policing history
this is not just make-believe every
single story in this series was based on
some real-life true event
we own this city as a book by justin
fenton yeah i've been a crime reporter
in baltimore since 2008 so i had a front
row seat to to all these stories
back when i was coming up police
officers used to
pull up on a crowd of people
jumped out of the car and they made all
of us lie down face first on the
concrete they all go and when i became a
journalist
i felt compelled to tell their stories
to tell my story to talk about what
we've been going through
there's something really gratifying
about working off the reel but then it
carries this
con commit responsibility in the
writer's room we had to argue out what
is it fair to say what is it not fair to
say the pandemic put us all in a
position where we actually could take a
year and a half to write this thing
george pelecanos and david simon their
research is second to none in the
writers room there was court documents
and all types of things stacked up to
the ceiling right we tried to film
mostly in the locations where the
incidents occurred
[Music]
you know where the shellings were placed
exactly the cross streets the type of
car the make the vehicle who was on the
streets
it feels authentic because it is
i'm nicole steele with the department of
justice nicole steele is one of the few
people in the show who's not based on
somebody who's real the costil is a
composite really of a number of
investigators with the civil rights
division we hold hands we twist arms ray
and david and george we all talked about
how nicole's character almost feels like
the audience she's watching this malay
of madness and asking why
there's a lot of discussion in the
writers room about the limits of the
federal government's consent decrees
given the continuing war against drugs
and through nicole steele's character we
get to see her struggling with that
[Music]
what happens if the police don't want to
change
we really wanted to pay attention not
only to what was happening in the
country's task force but what was
happening in the world around them
the conversation is bigger than a few
bad apples
the conversation should be about a
system that rewards officers for being
the bad apples i think baltimore is a
microcosm for what's happening all over
the country
on the ground get down on the ground hey
man that's some great [ __ ] police
work dog
it's yours you earned it
you